This is Blueprint. I'm Roman Mars. This is sight unseen. I'm Roman Mars. This is an ear for design. I'm Roman Mars. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Now that's nice. The name is important. It's the first thing, the tip of the spear, with any product you use or buy or see.
这是Blueprint。我是Roman Mars。这是“未见之物”（Sight Unseen）。我是Roman Mars。这是“设计之耳”（An Ear for Design）。我是Roman Mars。这是“99%隐形”（99% Invisible）。我是Roman Mars。这名字真不错。名字很重要。它是第一印象，是矛尖，是你使用、购买或看到的任何产品的先锋。
And you are bombarded by thousands of names every day. The name of this producer is Avery Trouffleman. And in the daily barrage of names, only the names that are most interesting, most pleasant on the tongue, can survive in your memory. If it's any kind of consumer product, like from PNG or Sony, or yeah, it's going to be a naming company that did it, you might not know it, but probably. And naming companies, as in companies that name things, are responsible for many of the proper nouns that you remember. Naming is just this weird little area and there's business, right? And then there's marketing and then there's branding and then there's naming and
你每天都被成千上万个名字轰炸。这位制作人的名字是Avery Trouffleman。在每天的名字轰炸中，只有那些最有趣、最顺口的名字才能留在你的记忆里。如果是任何消费品，比如来自宝洁（P&G）或索尼（Sony），或者其他什么，那很可能是一家命名公司做的，你可能不知道，但很可能是这样。命名公司，也就是那些专门为事物命名的公司，负责创造了许多你所记住的专有名词。命名只是一个奇怪的小领域，有商业，对吧？然后有市场营销，有品牌推广，然后才是命名，而
naming is so small. They're so really there's so few naming companies. There's like 20. And Laurel founded one of them. My name is Laurel Sutton. I'm one of the co-founders of Catchword. We're a naming firm here in the Bay Area. And Catchword comes from those guiding words at the top of a dictionary page. Those are the Catchwords. Most people don't know it. It doesn't matter. It just is what we do. So we're about words and we're about words that are catchy. She and her team have worked on everything. A line of yogurts for Chibani, the Palm Pre, Gap's Customer Rewards program, they have named as they put it. Everything except a car.
命名这个领域太小了。真的，命名公司很少。大概只有20家。Laurel创办了其中一家。我叫Laurel Sutton。我是Catchword的联合创始人之一。我们是湾区的一家命名公司。Catchword这个名字来源于字典页面顶部的引导词。那些就是“Catchwords”（词条）。大多数人不知道这一点。没关系。这正是我们的工作。所以我们专注于文字，专注于那些朗朗上口的文字。她和她的团队参与过各种项目。Chobani的一系列酸奶、Palm Pre手机、Gap的客户奖励计划，正如他们所说，他们命名过除了汽车以外的一切东西。
You might think, hey, I named my dog or my kids or my band or my blog. It's not too hard, but there are a number of things to consider when designing a name. Just think of all the associations with every word. Take for example, Photoshop elements. So we didn't name Photoshop, but we did come up with the elements part of it. And that word took a lot of work. Because Photoshop was looking to market
你可能会想，嘿，我给我的狗、我的孩子、我的乐队或我的博客都取过名字。这并不难，但在设计名字时有很多事情需要考虑。想想每个词所带来的所有联想。以Photoshop Elements为例。我们没有命名Photoshop，但我们想出了“Elements”这个部分。那个词花了很多功夫。因为Photoshop当时想要推销
a less expensive version of their software that had all the same capabilities as regular Photoshop, just without all the bells and whistles. You would think that that would be easy, but it wasn't. So they didn't want to use Photoshop light or Photoshop basic or anything that sounded compromising. So we went through a really large exploration of all the different ways that we could say just as good, but not as full, fledged.
一款更便宜的软件版本，它拥有与普通版Photoshop相同的所有功能，只是去掉了那些花哨的附加功能。你可能会觉得这很容易，但事实并非如此。他们不想用“Photoshop Light”或“Photoshop Basic”或任何听起来像是妥协的名字。所以我们进行了非常广泛的探索，寻找所有能表达“同样好，但没那么全面”的方法。
And we looked at essentials, we looked at just every word. And they chose elements for its subtlety. Elements are the most basic parts that you can have, but they're essentially, you can't have anything without elements. So that's the word that we eventually chose. And that's why you hire the experts to consider this stuff. And they don't come cheap.
我们研究了“Essentials”，我们研究了每一个词。他们最终选择了“Elements”，因为它很微妙。“Elements”（元素）是你所能拥有的最基本的部分，但它们是本质，没有元素你就什么都没有。所以这就是我们最终选择的词。这就是为什么你要雇佣专家来考虑这些事情。而且他们收费不菲。
The vast majority of naming companies like us are pretty expensive. But naming companies don't just make up names. They also check what names are available for URLs and for trademarks, and they see which names mean bad things and other languages. We can take any list of names and check them in any language in the world and say, is it pronounceable? Does it have negative meaning? And outside of the
绝大多数像我们这样的命名公司都相当昂贵。但命名公司不仅仅是编造名字。他们还会检查哪些名字可用于网址和商标，并查看哪些名字在其他语言中意味着不好的东西。我们可以拿任何名字列表，用世界上任何语言进行检查，看看它是否易于发音？是否有负面含义？而在
US, is there a brand already existing in your country or some of like a TV show that has the same name that we should be aware of? And you can't underestimate the importance of linguistic checks once they were naming a little gadget toy. And one of the names that we had come up with for them turned out in Japanese to be a word that meant a small device that doesn't work. So we took that one right off the list. But more than anything else, Laurel and her team at Catchword just produce a ton of names.
美国之外，你的国家是否已经存在一个品牌，或者是否有我们应该注意的同名电视节目？你不能低估语言检查的重要性。有一次他们正在为一个小玩具命名。我们为他们想出的名字之一，在日语中竟然是一个意思为“无法工作的小装置”的词。所以我们立刻把它从名单上删除了。但最重要的是，Laurel和她在Catchword的团队确实产出了大量的名字。
As Laurel sees it, there is a direct relationship between quantity and quality. You know, the first 500 names that you come up with are gonna be really obvious things. They're already taken. They're not gonna be that interesting. You kind of have to get that out. So catch word, we'll generate over 2,000 names. And they present 30 to 50 to the client. And they come up with so many freaking names
在Laurel看来，数量和质量之间存在直接关系。你知道，你最初想出的那500个名字通常都是非常显而易见的。它们已经被占用了。它们不会那么有趣。你必须先把这些东西排解掉。所以Catchword会生成超过2000个名字。然后他们向客户展示30到50个。他们想出这么多该死的名字，
because they come up with names across the naming spectrum. Okay, so we always draw a spectrum because we're talking about language, it's always a spectrum. So at one end of the spectrum, you have descriptive names. And those are names that absolutely just describe what the thing is. Classic example. Raising brand.
是因为他们是在整个命名范围内进行构思。好吧，我们总是画一个光谱，因为我们在谈论语言，它总是一个光谱。在光谱的一端，你有描述性名称。这些名字绝对只是描述了事物本身。经典的例子：葡萄干麦麸（Raisin Bran）。
Benefits of descriptive names. They are self-explanatory. That's what that stuff is, right? It's a box. It's brand and it has raisins in it. You would never have to. That's what that stuff is, right? It's a box, it's brand, and it has raisins in it. You would never have to explain to anybody what this stuff is. Shredded wheat. That's what that is. It's wheat, and it's been shredded. Drawbacks to descriptive names, they are hard to own. Normally, you can't trademark names like this. In fact, raisened brand and shredded wheat are not trademarks.
描述性名称的好处是：它们是不言自明的。这就是那东西，对吧？它是一个盒子。它是麦麸，里面有葡萄干。你永远不需要向任何人解释这东西是什么。碎麦片（Shredded Wheat）。这就是它。它是小麦，而且被切碎了。描述性名称的缺点是：它们很难拥有。通常，你不能为这样的名字注册商标。事实上，Raisin Bran和Shredded Wheat都不是商标。
Anybody can have a cereal and call it raisened brand or shredded wheat. So a lot of descriptive names tend to get modified. International business machines. Frity darn descriptive. Over time they've condensed that to IBM. The other big drawback is that descriptive names can be limited. If you remember there were companies called things like e-stamps, right? If you ever want to do anything but sell electronic stamps you're screwed. On the other end of the spectrum you've got so-called arbitrary names. And Apple is a great example of that.
任何人都可以生产一种麦片并称之为Raisin Bran或Shredded Wheat。所以很多描述性名称往往会被修改。国际商业机器公司（International Business Machines）。非常该死的描述性。随着时间的推移，他们将其缩写为IBM。另一个大缺点是描述性名称可能会受到限制。如果你还记得，曾经有一些公司叫“e-stamps”之类的名字，对吧？如果你以后想做除了卖电子邮票以外的任何事情，你就完蛋了。在光谱的另一端，你有所谓的任意名称。苹果（Apple）就是一个很好的例子。
It doesn't tell you anything about what they do, which allows for flexibility. They used to just make computers. Now they do media. They could do anything under that. I mean, they could make cars. But Apple is a real word that you can find in the dictionary, of course. It is its own set of associations. Maybe Apple implies learning or freshness, I don't know. But it doesn't apply to the thing, it's naming. Arbitrary names can also just be completely made up.
它没有告诉你任何关于他们做什么的信息，这提供了灵活性。他们过去只制造电脑。现在他们做媒体。他们可以在此名下做任何事情。我的意思是，他们甚至可以制造汽车。但Apple当然是一个可以在字典里找到的真实单词。它有自己的一套联想。也许Apple暗示了学习或新鲜感，我不知道。但它并不适用于产品本身，这就是命名。任意名称也可以是完全编造出来的。
And these kinds are called empty vessels. Some examples are Hulu or Exxon or Xerox or Kodak. Kodak has absolutely no meaning. They only chose it because that great hard K sound is very acoustically relevant. That is, it really cuts through. We tend to say that things that start with that hard K sound are strong. Things that start with T, also the same way. It's kind of a strong, more aggressive sounding name, whereas an F sound is very soft It's a little harder to hear it and people just don't respond as well to it the benefits of arbitrary names and empty vessel names
这类名字被称为“空容器”（Empty Vessels）。一些例子是Hulu、Exxon、Xerox或Kodak。Kodak完全没有意义。他们选择它只是因为那个响亮的K音在声学上非常相关。也就是说，它真的很响亮。我们倾向于说以硬K音开头的名字很强。以T开头的名字也是一样。这是一种听起来更强、更具侵略性的名字，而F音则非常柔和。它听起来有点难，人们对它的反应也不太好。任意名称和空容器名称的好处是：
They're easy to trademark easy to get the domain name for and usually good in languages around the world drawback They are hard to market you have to explain them to people You know you had a lot of money behind these kinds of names to tell people what they mean. Right. Okay, so you've got descriptive on one end of the spectrum, an arbitrary on the other, and most names fall somewhere in between the two, and Laurel calls all these names in the middle suggestive names.
它们很容易注册商标，容易获得域名，而且通常在世界各地的语言中表现良好。缺点是：它们很难推销，你必须向人们解释它们。你知道，你必须在这些名字背后投入大量资金来告诉人们它们的含义。好吧。所以光谱的一端是描述性的，另一端是任意的，大多数名字都落在两者之间，Laurel把中间这些名字称为暗示性名称。
They're not exactly arbitrary, and they're not exactly descriptive, like Microsoft. Microsoft software for microcomputers, right? It kind of says what it does, but not really because it's those two words that are smushed together like that. Microsoft is an example of a coined word, a word that doesn't exist in the English dictionary, but it's made up of familiar words, word parts, or sounds. Spotify and Nescafe and Netflix are also coin words. They sound like English words, but they're not. And Laurel and her team generate tons of coin words from lists of root words.
它们不完全是任意的，也不完全是描述性的，比如Microsoft。微型计算机的软件（Microcomputer software），对吧？它有点说明了它的功能，但又不完全是，因为它是两个词拼在一起。Microsoft是一个“合成词”（coined word）的例子，一个在英语字典中不存在的词，但它是由熟悉的词、词根或声音组成的。Spotify、Nescafe和Netflix也是合成词。它们听起来像英语单词，但其实不是。Laurel和她的团队从词根列表中生成了大量的合成词。
You try to find the right vocabulary for the client. And what are they trying to convey in this name? Make a list of vocabulary and then you think, OK, how could I modify these words? And then we have lists of prefixes and suffixes in English. And then you just start parenthemma. For example, take the root name. From there you can get nameling,
你试图为客户找到合适的词汇。他们想通过这个名字传达什么？列出一个词汇表，然后你思考，好吧，我该如何修改这些词？然后我们有英语的前缀和后缀列表。然后你就开始……例如，以“name”这个词根为例。从那里你可以得到Nameling、
namely, rename, name spot, name pro, pro name. But okay, let's be honest. There are lots of websites that can mash prefixes and suffixes to words and generate big long lists for you. But websites are not linguists. They can't tell you what names are actually good. That's where the skill and the creative talent comes in is figuring out what's a good word.
Namely、Rename、Name Spot、Name Pro、Pro Name。但是，好吧，说实话。有很多网站可以将前缀和后缀与单词混合，并为你生成一大长串列表。但网站不是语言学家。它们无法告诉你哪些名字实际上是好的。这就是技巧和创造性天赋发挥作用的地方，即找出什么是好词。
And you wouldn't think it, but suggestive names are really difficult to create because you want them to have meaning? A lot of them are taken? Tak taken for domain names and trademarks. And as Laurel sees it, it doesn't hurt to have 2,000 options. But it doesn't have to be this way. There are other people who do it very differently. They do 10 names at a time. That works for them. I think it depends on whether you come from more strictly a naming background or whether you come from an ad agency background and you do it that way.
你可能想不到，但暗示性名称真的很难创造，因为你希望它们有意义？其中很多已经被占用了。被域名和商标占用了。在Laurel看来，有2000个选择并没有坏处。但情况不一定非得这样。还有其他人做得很不一样。他们一次只做10个名字。这对他们来说很有效。我认为这取决于你是来自纯粹的命名背景，还是来自广告代理背景，并以那种方式进行。
We tend to present around 12 names, just because if you present too many in the value of any given name is drastically reduced. Eli Altman is the creative director at 100 Monkeys. Another naming company only a few miles away. Ulyse Company got its name from the idea that if you put 100 Monkeys in front of 100 typewriters you're bound to get a good name.
我们倾向于展示大约12个名字，因为如果你展示太多，任何给定名字的价值都会大幅降低。Eli Altman是100 Monkeys的创意总监。另一家命名公司，距离这里只有几英里。100 Monkeys这个名字来源于一个想法：如果你把100只猴子放在100台打字机前，你一定会得到一个好名字。
It's kind of a joke about the process. They give their client a list of 12 names. It's not like 100 Monkeys produces fewer names because they're lazier. These guys just have a really different philosophy to naming. Some people think that naming is about linguistics. We are not of that philosophy. Names are all about the stories that they begin to tell.
这有点像关于这个过程的笑话。他们给客户一份12个名字的名单。这并不是说100 Monkeys因为懒惰而产出的名字更少。这些人对命名有着非常不同的哲学。有些人认为命名是关于语言学的。我们不持有这种哲学。名字关乎它们开始讲述的故事。
Eli and his team do not make coined words or empty vessels. I just don't think that's maybe the most productive way to think about names is like sort of mixing with prefixes, creating portmanteaux, things like that. We're much more interested in history of a word and backstory than inventing. Really, these guys are very into mythology and narrative. At the meeting I sat in on, one name was a small town in Europe where a famous mathematician was born.
Eli和他的团队不制造合成词或空容器。我只是认为，通过混合前缀、创造混成词等方式来思考名字，可能不是最有效的方法。我们对一个词的历史和背景故事比发明创造更感兴趣。真的，这些人非常热衷于神话和叙事。在我旁听的会议上，其中一个名字是欧洲的一个小镇，一位著名的数学家就出生在那里。
Others were inspired by anatomical charts and constellations. 100 monkeys has the dinner party in mind, names that lead to conversation. And in this way, Eli and his team have named front porch senior living communities, the Lot, which is the Rhode Island state lottery, start here, the Microsoft Windows Tutorial. Yeah, they've named a lot of different things.
其他的灵感来自解剖图和星座。100 Monkeys考虑的是晚宴，即那些能引发对话的名字。通过这种方式，Eli和他的团队命名了Front Porch养老社区、The Lot（罗德岛州彩票）、Start Here（微软Windows教程）。是的，他们命名过很多不同的东西。
Companies, products, services, theories. You've named theories? Yeah, it's true. It's called conditioned hyper-eating. A theory for how fast food companies design food to make it irresistible. Okay, conditioned hyper-eating was kind of a departure for a hundred monkeys. Normally they go for more poetic names. You know, it's just really about finding as many interesting words as you can from secret service code names to rundown theaters to types of wind and ocean currents.
公司、产品、服务、理论。你们命名过理论？是的，是真的。它叫“条件性过度进食”（Conditioned Hyper-eating）。这是一个关于快餐公司如何设计食物使其令人无法抗拒的理论。好吧，条件性过度进食对100 Monkeys来说是一种偏离。通常他们会选择更具诗意的名字。你知道，这真的只是关于尽可能多地找到有趣的词，从特勤局代号到破旧的剧院，再到风和洋流的类型。
And so whereas Laurel sees a naming spectrum, Eli envisions sort of a name taxonomy, and the classifications break down and down and down into 25 species. 25 categories of names, which he lists in his book, don't call it that. Names that are about people, Tesla, Jack Daniels, Invented characters, Jolly Green, Giant, Mr. Clean, names that feel like they have history in them, the inner public, crowned royal. And it's not like some of these categories are good and some are bad. There are just a lot of options.
所以，当Laurel看到一个命名光谱时，Eli设想了一种命名分类法，分类不断细分，细分为25个物种。25个名字类别，他在他的书《别叫那个名字》（Don't Call It That）中列出了这些类别。关于人的名字：Tesla、Jack Daniels；虚构角色：Jolly Green Giant、Mr. Clean；感觉有历史感的名字：The Inner Public、Crown Royal。并不是说其中一些类别是好的，一些是坏的。只是有很多选择。
It mostly comes down to what kind of story, if any, you want behind your name. Some clients really want a meaningless name. Remember, made-up names are easier to register domains or trademarks for and are less likely to offend. And if it's a meaningless word, if it's just a completely coined made-up word, you can make up any story you want around it. A name like Hulu, for example. As far as I know, it doesn't actually have any real meaning. I know that Hulu, the inventors of that, have a story around that name.
这主要归结为你想要名字背后有什么样的故事（如果有的话）。有些客户确实想要一个毫无意义的名字。记住，编造的名字更容易注册域名或商标，也不太可能冒犯他人。如果它是一个毫无意义的词，如果它只是一个完全编造的合成词，你可以在它周围编造任何你想要的故事。比如Hulu这个名字。据我所知，它实际上没有任何真正的含义。我知道Hulu的创始人围绕那个名字编了一个故事。
I don't think it's true. But it's a cool name because it's short. It's easy to remember. Visually, it's very interesting looking. So no, you don't need to have a story around it. The long and short event is this. If you've got enough money, you could pick any old name to do it. You could pick a name as meaningless as Hulu. Yep, money talks. If you have a ton of money, basically the name could be anything. Remember when the iPad was about to come out,
我不认为那是真的。但它是一个很酷的名字，因为它很短。它很容易记住。在视觉上，它看起来非常有趣。所以不，你不需要围绕它编一个故事。长话短说就是这样。如果你有足够的钱，你可以选择任何旧名字来做这件事。你可以选择像Hulu这样毫无意义的名字。是的，金钱万能。如果你有大量的钱，基本上名字可以是任何东西。还记得iPad快要出来的时候吗？
everyone thought it was the silliest name. You heard all kinds of sanitary napkin jokes. But now, through sheer force of will and advertising dollars, you don't think twice about it. But with a name like iPad, at least you can pronounce it. Can you imagine reading Xerox for the first time? Xerox. X rox. Xerox.
每个人都认为这是最愚蠢的名字。你听到了各种关于卫生巾的笑话。但现在，凭借纯粹的意志力和广告投入，你根本不会再多想了。但对于像iPad这样的名字，至少你可以读出来。你能想象第一次读Xerox吗？Xerox。X rox。Xerox。
Xerox. Before they get their new name, companies and products usually have little internal code names or nicknames, like Project X or they get named after someone's cat or something like that. Sometimes, unfortunately, with big companies this will often happen, they will have a code name that someone internally has chosen, which is actually pretty good, and people get very attached to it. And then we have to convince them that they can't use it because it's probably not available as a trademark. So sometimes we have a little ceremony, like a grave thing. Seriously, we've actually done this where we have a, in our briefing, we'll put up a little slide where it shows a grave and then we'll have the code name on there.
Xerox。在获得新名字之前，公司和产品通常有一些内部代号或昵称，比如Project X，或者以某人的猫的名字命名之类的。有时，不幸的是，大公司经常会发生这种情况，他们会有一个内部人员选择的代号，其实还不错，人们会对它产生很深的感情。然后我们必须说服他们不能使用它，因为它可能无法注册为商标。所以有时我们会举行一个小仪式，像葬礼一样。说真的，我们确实做过这样的事，在我们的简报中，我们会放一张小幻灯片，上面显示一个坟墓，然后把代号写在上面。
And we'll say, okay, now we're going to have a monosilence for your code name because you can't have it. So you have to let it go. We all sit there for a minute. Okay, now we're going to think about the new name. So what should we name this episode? Uh, well I was going to call it what's in a name? I will slap you so hard if you call it what's in a name. I really will.
我们会说，好吧，现在我们要为你的代号默哀一分钟，因为你不能使用它了。所以你必须放手。我们都坐在那里一分钟。好吧，现在我们要考虑新名字了。那么我们应该给这一集起什么名字呢？嗯，我本来想叫它“名字里有什么？”（What's in a name?）。如果你叫它“名字里有什么？”，我会狠狠地扇你一巴掌。真的会。
So yeah, apparently everybody's used that title to talk about naming. And then I thought I'd go for something, you know, settler, like a rose by any other. And I will also slap you if you call it that too. Man, 90% of the articles that we've been quoted in have either been what's in a name or a rose by any other name. Those have been the headlines on those.
所以，显然每个人都用过那个标题来谈论命名。然后我想我应该选一个，你知道，更文雅的，比如“玫瑰即使换个名字”（a rose by any other）。如果你也叫它那个，我也会扇你一巴掌。天哪，我们被引用的文章中90%要么是“名字里有什么？”，要么是“玫瑰即使换个名字”。这些都是那些文章的标题。
Just awful. So I don't know what to call this episode. Help. What should we call it? Oh, I don't know. I don't know. I'd have to give it some thought. I can't name on the fly like that.
简直太糟糕了。所以我不知道该给这一集起什么名字。救命。我们应该叫它什么？哦，我不知道。我不知道。我得好好想想。我不能就这样随口起名。
Title TK. Wait, I don't get it. Why TK? Title TK means title yet to come. Like we'll fill it in later. If you're working in any newsroom, you know like if you don't know what the headline is or some little piece of research instead of stopping and figuring it out, you just type in TK and then your editor knows that you're going to go back and fill it in later. Shouldn't it be TC? Well I was taught that TK stood out better on the page so that you won't miss it when you're going back and revise me.
Title TK。等等，我不明白。为什么是TK？Title TK的意思是“标题待定”（Title yet to come）。就像我们以后再填补它一样。如果你在任何新闻编辑室工作，你知道，如果你不知道标题是什么，或者某段研究资料还没弄好，你不用停下来去搞清楚，你只需输入TK，你的编辑就知道你会回去填补它。不应该是TC吗？嗯，我被教导说TK在页面上更显眼，这样当你回去修改时就不会错过它。
Makes sense, right? 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffleman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KLW in San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook.
有道理，对吧？本周的《99%隐形》由Avery Truffleman制作，Katie Mingle、Sam Greenspan和我Roman Mars参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的ArcSign办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。
All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible, you must go to 99pi.org. Rx. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。Rx。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。